my name is Faris and welcome to ya
together early shine I decided I'm rude
I know how good I am at dancing oh hey I
like it spin oh wait what alright I got
his hands on the ball a little bit all
right why don't we got here is that a
map it's a map
collect all 9 breaths collect oh that's
really one is first day holy [ __ ] I'm
slow so where am I ok I start there it's
a very nifty map design I gotta give him
that I'm glad I have a map whoever made
this a Hager if I activate ok but twitch
- better dress down okay
I'll be sure to twist them oh I get it
like I'm going in chair motor whenever I
click the [ __ ] thing all right let's
get the ah you [ __ ] bow I did not
expect that J's this guy alright alright
there really is battle son of a [ __ ]
all right we got sharp mr. chair
we got Agrippa now how the hell we
probably should finish this side off
first so let's go over here I don't like
this
chairborne angry oh man this is too good
oh okay oh is this oh it's buffet of
course taking straight for
I'm pretty sure that's illegal chair
mode activate
but her guests that [ __ ] alright tonight
I'm gonna pick bad
ah [ __ ] my friend forget that's a sweet
happy face what
[Music]
goddamnit bad
it's [ __ ] haunting me it's raping
know what game over
why what happened did I die [ __ ] I think
I died that's right alright I guess I'll
I'll I'll change tactics
alright best map design chime or
activate me oh I got something I gotta
do brush I keep telling you Jennifer
I've never been this happy to see you
come here
shovel wax I keep telling you brush all
this chair mode when in doubt alright
mr. sheriff there you are thankfully all
right back baby
works every time aiyee all right
think you gotta go back all this way
later that's not good
no sir no siree Brizzy bars yeah what a
great me but I don't even see anything
all right that won't activate man I
gotta save me bro save my dad I can
write down all right here we go reg
don't even worry about it
[ __ ] best game ever
I'll give this a thousand out of ten bro
points huh that's a lot of bro points
Jace's guys so many brooklyn-born
activating you see these barrels this is
why you can't share mode because you're
a [ __ ] barrel that's why that's right
barrel Barry boo that's your new name
all right what do we got Bernie come
here baby girl
funny girl I mean j-roc Vic all right
there we go
now I just got to make it all the way
back ah who would have thought barrels
are so [ __ ] scary Jase this guy all
right keep going we can do this breaths
don't even worry about it we're gonna
finish this I'm pip I if I don't finish
this it's embarrassing Wow
hi I'm so fast on the shower mode you
have no idea
that was a close one but that was a
closely clue
don't kill me Merrill ah yeah Charlotte
saved my life a million times it's
blazing it all right
I made it so far I got I got I gotta
finish it I tried so far to lose it all
I don't know what I'm doing
hmm battles can't do that that's why I'm
doing it Oh what do I got
why did I take the long route god oh
wait there's only one right yeah don't
look at me like I didn't know what I'm
doing all right let's go through Hey all
right
everything seems to be and all that all
I hope I'm not that bad all right let's
go around around the world hey hey okay
Cheryl activate come on what seven out
of nine what does that mean so close
piggy oh we got a place to start
I'm so stupid I'm boom-boom I'm so
freakin palm oh he's back there all
right I'm coming for you spine eyes
don't even worry about it all right all
right
goddamnit
we got to do this dress we came so far
what am I going there we go
I totally know what I'm doing don't even
worry about it you were worried I know
how to I'm the ultimate barrel fighter
so far ah I'm coming for you bro ah son
of a buck
oh my [ __ ] my everything just give it to
fire and fire less pity ah
[Music]
yeah
all right
[Music]
anyway [ __ ] idea Mutis thank you
brother for making this that was a lot
of fun quite a thrill I gotta leave a
download in the description back a bit
if she enjoyed subscribe he would come
up really today and I'll see you next
episode III so much fun that you fence
and gross make these kind of stuff for
me I it really really makes you
appreciate ah yeah bra realize you
forever exam be gesture yeah you make
her that's re-site kids are not kids is
Crescent never again peanut butter
either
alright it's giving a lot of credit I
guess I'll keep this rolling ah this
funds writing nice things about me I
thought they were writing nice things to
them
oh it sounds sweet ah it brothers are
the greatest you got me you go pin pin
had a nose line james ingram not fun but
there are always had to share me on
thanks for excessive magma ah i'll
appeared in breakfast breakfast thank
you
if it is i play video don't you would
keep doing it for a long time i would be
sure to write for like probably know
ah don't worry about it
hey my father amazing.i does too much so
much you're making me you're making me
watery in my eyes all right
ethnic press hangover everything we
should have used safe thing that's
cheating
karmana does not cheat I'm thinking
viewing your car on the [ __ ]